so the ESG global warming agenda is part
of the reason our economy is tanking the
other part is Ukraine
we are pushing in fact engaging in a hot
war with Russia at this moment which is
upended Energy prices around the world
and it's getting worse the US Congress
is somehow earmarked more than 90
billion dollars to Ukraine just this
year that's double what we spent
annually in Afghanistan that's far more
than Russia's entire annual military
budget but it's still not enough for the
president of Ukraine zielinski he
doesn't ask the U.S Congress for money
he demands it
here he is over the last three months
watch this
we absolutely need the United States to
show leadership and give Ukraine the air
defense system but believe me it it's
not even nearly enough to cover the
civilian infrastructure schools
hospitals universities homes of
ukrainians we have two key financial
needs of the country that's 38 billion
dollars to make up for the deficit of
our budget for next year and other 17
billion dollars that were verified by
the World Bank and needed to rebuild the
critical infrastructure we would really
like for the support especially the
amount of support to stay the same and
to have this joint support from the U.S
society and above all U.S tax buyers
because at the end of the day this is
not the money of the government but the
money of the people
do you know that guy who is that guy
he's some Ukrainian corrupt strong man
really and he's demanding money from us
the gall of that guy where does he get
off outside wood is the founder of CD
media and former Special Operations
pilot he joins us today Ty thanks so
much for coming on so the questions
zelenski is where does he get this
attitude he's not a supplicant
he is someone who's demanding the U.S
Congress fund his government not just
his War but the salaries of his
bureaucrats like where does he get this
attitude
look zielinski used was brought to Power
by an oligarch named ahor kolomoski
which he recently went after and
targeted for persecution in Ukraine so
that tells me something that uh
zielinski now has a bigger and more
important and more powerful and more
Rich benefactor and that being the Biden
Administration the world economic forum
and the cabal that's pushing all this
agenda on the United States so zelinski
is not working for the people of Ukraine
they're suffering massively you know we
have had a team on the ground for since
maidan in 2014 and we're being told now
for months they're saying where is all
this Aid that's supposed to be coming
here we're not seeing anything we're
having teams having to go into Poland
with our own funds and buy food for the
people buy medical supplies a large
percentage of the Ukrainian population
right now has no water or electricity or
heat going into the winter think about
that and a lot of them in these
high-rise you know soviet-built build
buildings so it's really a disaster
zielinski is working for a bigger agenda
not for the Ukrainian people that's for
sure
so 90 billion dollars there's been no
audit of where that money went Democrats
in the Congress are fighting an audit
why wouldn't they want to know
well because approximately you know this
is you got to realize this is the
varsity team of money launderers in
Ukraine we're estimating that only 30
percent of the the supplies in in
military aid is actually getting to the
where it needs are supposed to go
there's been evidence which we talked
about on your Show recently of a plane
crash in Greece where arms were being
shipped overseas and so uh this money is
not getting where it's supposed to go
the uh a lot of this money is going to
Offshore you know we're talking about
homes uh you know there's credible
reports that a lot of these Ukrainian
officials have bought a property
offshore they don't want peace they want
the money trained to continue for the
you know defense contractors in the U.S
and and I I'm fascinated to see what's
going to happen when the the house gets
taken over by the GOP and hopefully this
money train stops so we'll see I hope so
and then you see decent reasonable
conservative people nice people like
Joni Ernst
backing this I mean a lot of Republicans
need to wake up and understand they've
been had in a in a very profound way
else I would I appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you so much thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight